so finally we have got drew and ross the
rise of a whole new kind of party
apartment therapy reports that people
are getting together for potluck and
powerpoint nights so this is when you
invite your friends over and everyone
takes a turn at giving a powerpoint
presentation of their choice on any
topic they're excited about videos of
these parties are showing up on tick
tock with creative presentations like my
exes from most to least traumatizing
or
my friends as beyonce song
for us
yeah drew what would your powerpoint
topic be um well i love this like that
you had me at potluck right
just bring your favorite hot dish over
but the powerpoint threw me for a loop
one because i don't know how to do a
powerpoint yeah do you and number two
what what i i do and i really thought
long and hard about this and if you were
coming drew to mine i would put a
powerpoint together of my favorite
people from 90 day fiance and i would
walk you through this is big ed big ed's
been through a lot number one do you
watch 90 days
finally someone else on this channel
watch his 90-day fiance yeah missing out
especially during these troubled times
it's just what the doctor is exactly
it's really i mean i know i have a
series to promote but
really
focus your attention on 90 day fiance
and um june what was your power point
i had to say i'm with ross like mine
would be on just simply how to make a
power point like that's really what i'd
have to drill down on because i barely
know how to update my computer like i
keep on seeing that little that little
notice pop up and i say x
not today
i totally agree what would your
powerpoint be mine yeah what would you
do every day we do it right here at
drew's news this is my daily powerpoint
of all things that are happening in the
world that are good funny irreverent
interesting and
hopefully life affirming and shows
companies changing this is the kind of
news i need so this is my powerpoint
presentation
june diane rayfield catch the final
season of grace and frankie on netflix
um starting april 29th and i just love
you let's do this show together forever
and i will never get up exactly yeah and
i just love kim kardashian you know i've
got skims on right now by the way i
love it oh my god
ready hold on
kim kardashian
[Applause]
um
that's how much i love kim kardashian
makes a good product i'm wearing you're
in this region i i love her i love you i
love casey i love you and i love your
husband paul who really set the tone for
how we could make a show and a pandemic
and bring people to this news desk and
we have followed his model ever since
and again i don't know if we can benefit
financially from that but
yeah okay
[Music]